[Music]
welcome
to an episode of honest trailer
commentaries
uh where we're talking everything wanda
vision we're gonna give you our behind
the scenes
thoughts and feelings we're gonna go
into depth into serious detail while we
watch the honest trailer with you
then we're gonna do some uh cut scenes
and jokes didn't make it into the final
cut
we're gonna respond to questions and
comments from viewers like yourself so
keep them coming in the chat
then we're gonna tease you with next
week's australia hopefully i'll get it
right this week
uh with me as always lon harris danny
radford
hello hello hey welcome to the hex um
what are you i'm gonna grieve throughout
this episode just a few things totally
existed
what is grief if not lawn persevering um
what do you uh what what's your overall
takeaway after uh after you've seen all
of wanda vision how do you feel how
are you feeling about uh marvel's first
foray into uh into television
at the mcu at least i loved it i really
liked it um
it was appointment tv for me at least as
much i wasn't one of the people that
stayed up until like midnight but i
definitely would like get up a little
bit earlier so i could catch it before
all the spoilers came
um i really liked it i again this is
another one of those
um those things where it takes movies
that maybe weren't
my favorite and it adds context to them
so i can go back and appreciate it like
i have an appreciation for age of ultron
now
um and yeah i just like when you take
some of these because wanda's like a big
character but she's not like one of the
big
big mcu characters so taking her and
getting to do a story on that
that's the kind of stuff that i live for
as a comic fan anyway it feels like this
is her
mini series um so yeah i loved it i
thought it was great
lon what do you think you old curmudgeon
uh so i this was a real case of like i i
think the premise here like the concept
when it's explained
is brilliant like very clever a cool
thing to do with marvel comics
i really thought that uh the actors did
an amazing job of like
recreating these old styles like
elizabeth olsen and paul bentley and
catherine han they just slipped on like
50s and 60s and 70s sitcom banter like
it was nothing and that's not easy to do
they're very
specific modes so i liked all a lot of
stuff about it but i did
feel like the execution was just kind of
off the the structure especially the
show felt really
repetitive to me i felt like it was like
week five week six
and the characters were still talking
about stuff like i felt like was pretty
clear by
week two or week three and it just felt
like it really dragged on and then at
the end
i'll admit that i i think um you know i
didn't find it totally satisfying how
like action oriented it became at the
end and the end just became like let's
tie this into all the other marvel stuff
and let's give you a big action finale
when a lot of the stuff that the show
was doing and was raising earlier i
thought was like more interesting than
vision forehead laser battles yeah i
mean i certainly enjoyed the first half
more than the second half and i didn't
mind the pacing because i just found it
so enjoyable to watch them
recreate sitcoms together and throw in
the like one weird thing of the week
i i can honestly have just watched them
recreate different classic tv shows
um for for eight weeks and then finally
bring in the outside world
so i sadly like i kind of got bummed
every time we left the hex and went into
like more traditional marvel territory
of like oh here's the military base
up they've got a plan oh your plan's
better than my plan no it's gonna be my
plan uh we we kind of fell into that
again
and but overall like like danielle said
it was appointment television like i was
i definitely wanted to know more
um did they pay off everything
you be the judge i think that that
finale
for me was like kind of uh like the
pants fell down off of the clown and it
tripped over its own clown penis that
that's a weird metaphor
but it's but that's how it's very
specific very specific
i mean it's a well-endowed clown so i
feel like
they do and i'm not asking i definitely
don't want my
uh uh tv shows to be morally
prescriptive and be like
you should feel this way about this
person because they did this thing but i
do think it just
the show wasn't clear where it came down
on on wanda um at the end of the day
like
and yes i obviously she's now a morally
gray character but i feel like the show
was bending over backwards to
make the audience still on her side
which is fine
i mean you can do that but i just didn't
i felt like
there was never the the reckoning that
she deserved like she
got away scot-free with torturing a
whole lot of people and it's like
you sacrificed so much it's like your
your boyfriend died i'm sorry like that
happens
these people are alive and have families
uh and i don't think it ever had the it
spent so much time
with wanda's grief and and the
processing of that and it really pushed
to the wayside like
uh or and minimized what she was doing
to uh
to all these people in my opinion um so
i i felt like it was kind of morally
muddled at the end
um in a way that i don't think was
intentional
i mean i think this is an interesting
thing for the mcu as a whole because the
mcu's kind of already
had this conversation with itself it was
the sokovia accords and civil war was
like
here's the side that's like no no
superheroes do have to answer to
authority just like anyone else
and then here's the side that's like no
we're the heroes we're the ones who
should be deciding how to use our powers
and it's like now that that never got
settled it ended up becoming a
personality clash between tony stark and
steve rogers
and it's like well but that question is
now still very much up on the air and
we really like we've kind of already
dealt with it but we really have not
dealt with it at all
and i i do feel like that's what feige
is sort of leading us into like this is
going to become a theme throughout
phase four i would suspect and it's
always with wanda too like get it
together girl
yes well she already had a i mean right
in age of ultron we already saw her go
from the
i'm using my powers to like work out
these personal grievances versus no i'm
gonna become an avenger and i'm gonna
use them
for like the common good and now yeah
she's sort of replaying that conflict
again
yeah well she's got a lot of collateral
damage it's piling up
um she didn't know she was like stronger
than doctor strange back then though you
know you reconsider
over time yeah yeah well we'll see and
then
the other thing like but i definitely
appreciate this i think like danielle
said
is that it's kind of filling in the
blanks with the side characters um
because i feel like just like with cap
and bucky
like the romance between these two was
90 created by like fan desire
like they just kind of like wheeled it
into existence like
because re-watching their scenes
together in ultron like
i guess they maybe had like a robot's
idea of a flirtatious moment
and that's it and then you see them in
civil war and they're dating for two
years but i feel like but
between those two movies it was just
tumblr like willing and into existence
so this was good in fleshing out their
relationship
i think they had an uphill battle
because the whole like we've seen a lot
more
their relationship is almost entirely
defined by them being pulled apart we've
seen
very little of them together and almost
all them having
be tragically separated over and over
again i actually thought one of the best
scenes in the entire show
of course it's the one that's being
quoted all the time with the the
is when we sort of flash back to when
they were living at the avengers
compound together and vision just kind
of comes into a room
it it does a lot in one seat it's got
one scene to basically show us the
entire growth of this relationship like
how it went from
co-workers to being in love and then
running away to scotland together
and i thought for having to do so much
of that one seat it's actually
pretty well put together and effective
although i think chronologically
after that scene takes place wanda puts
vision in a big hole
so that hawkeye can escape a big ol hole
um you know hey a lover's coral a
lover's fat who hasn't put there
hawk i was the first avenger to like
help her out man you know
yeah plus the vision would have got that
paprika right then maybe he wouldn't
have landed in a hole
i thought he nailed it oh yeah no no
she tries it and is like that's not
peppercorn yeah
all right anyways he doesn't eat he
doesn't have taste buds come on what
does he know
we'll say more as we watch together the
honest trailer for
one division
the following broadcast is rated s for
spoilers
thank you for that custom graphic copy
do you like tv shows
how about a tv show about some tv shows
about some tv shows that is a tv show
washed by the characters inside a tv
show
wandavision the tv show
you said huh when they bonded over their
vaguely defined superpowers
i'm still me i think do you know i don't
know what this
is you said oh okay when they date it
for two years off camera
wonder for two years we stole these
moments
and you thought well i guess that's over
when this happened
but ever since cap left bucky for this
homewrecker wanda and vision are the
closest thing marvel has to a healthy
relationship
even though she's torturing a small town
with her mind when you let us sleep
we have your nightmares your grief is
poisoning us
and he's her imaginary vibrator
programmed only to love
you can't control me the way you do them
can't i
watch this i don't know if you could
hear it in in this playing and and
usually
we have a policy if there's no altering
the clips in any way this is after all
honest trailers we're not kind of
uh adding on but we did add a subtle
vibrator noise to that scene
just once the rules are made to be
broken and once in a while you gotta
just go for it and uh i thought that
gave it the extra
the extra spice in the paw precautious
word
is to have fission vibrate like that um
i also wanted to do a little
uh around the mcu relationship check-in
if they really are the healthiest
relationship at this point in the mcu
though there's like star-lord and
gamora well it's a different it's a
gamora from a different timeline who
doesn't even know him
so they're pretty only kinda they're
pretty far down the list
yeah peter parker and mj maybe are they
are they together at this point they are
right at the end of high schoolers
though i don't know
i mean yeah they know they know they you
know they know how one another feels at
this point it feels like they're up
they're embarking on a new romance so
that that seems like it's a pretty
healthy
pair what about happy and aunt may
yeah yeah is he because it seems a lot
like he
she's leaving him one-sided but we don't
i don't know if we have total
confirmation on that
tony's dead so that's an improvement
over their relationship tony
pepper they were they were pretty solid
when we saw them in end games she's
she's reading about compost he's getting
ice pops you know yeah
but that but that's done um unless he's
gonna be some new jarvis or something
like that
oh oh hang on uh clint
clinton laura barton very happily
married reunited three kids
they're on a farm i don't know hot dogs
that seems very it's really just a
matter of time before she said
so what did you do while we were uh well
we were blipped
what'd you get up to nice haircut what's
with the tattoos
a lot of murder for hire listen he left
her
phone account active for five full years
just in case she ever came back and
needed to call him that if that's not
true love i don't know what it is
learning can't go to mexico it's fine
yeah like you know
att was like checking in like you sure
and he's like leave it
again these superheroes are getting away
scot-free for uh
grief is explaining away a lot of murder
[Music]
killing gang he's just basically just
batmanning and
people of his own yeah he is judge jerry
an executioner he decided oh you
you know uh you make breakfast for the
cartel well you get the blade
you know what you were getting into yeah
you know what you're getting into our
version of
uh avengers endgame that we used for
honest trailers does not have subtitles
on it and i've sometimes gone back to
watch it so i now have seen avengers end
game in that scene
with uh hawkeye killing that guy in
tokyo like five times
with no subtitles i don't remember what
they even say
it's just japanese yeah sometimes that
happens because we
uh we watch like digital versions of
these
um purchased legally uh but sometimes
they don't have the subtitles and i
remember i watched um
it was like rise of the planet of the
apes and uh
for about 30 minutes before i realized
that they had the apes
subtitles in the real version yeah it's
like wow they're really going for this
this is so experimental
so at this point i like legit don't
remember what hawkeye and that guy
talk about and i like to invent it
myself i have my own
narrative for that book there you go uh
i forgot what we were talking about so
let's just keep watching the trailer
watch this power couple cosplay through
some of history's most delightful
sitcoms
from modern family it's probably just a
case of the mondays
to malcolm in the middle mom's been
weird since uncle pietro got here
to the show's boomers love because they
literally had no other options
take out the papers and the trash oh you
won't get me spending cash
but every once in a while this super
computer manages to calculate
something about all this might not be on
the up and up i have questions
what is it how did this happen she came
here because we're all what
what what's that about what aren't you
telling me why are there no other
children in muslim no am
why would you think that i guess you are
[Music]
because the big question i mean vision
has some selective
uh memory loss i guess and is that
caused by wander is that just because
he's like
theoretically like a baby he's like two
years old but he's like a baby with a
dictionary in his brain
so it's like she created him
like physically manifested some version
of him but i think we were never
totally clear on how much of the
original vision was in this new one
versus how much was like an original
maximoff joint yeah
i just don't see him yeah nobody
nobody discusses though if she because
they're monitoring from outside the
hecks they're monitoring vision by
tracking vibranium which means that
wanda was able to mentally create
vibranium out of nothing well no she
stole his corpse right
no no she doesn't remember she in that
scene when she's in the the plot that
was going to be their house and she's
overcome with grief she doesn't have
vision's body with her
she's just like he just like gets
generated
out of her via her chaos magic and my
question is
it doesn't even occur to hayward like
you just got the goose that lays the
golden vibranium baby
just like yeah the creatures in its
supply of vibranium
is the vision from the thing the corpse
vision right yes he creates white vision
out of vision's old body and then it
flies away
still you know three billion dollars
worth of vibranium out of skylight
good job dude but i figured that like
yeah
that she that hayward's plan would have
been something like that i think i
predicted like oh they're using this as
a plot for her to like generate
super beings and then they're gonna like
just keep harvesting them out of the hex
like as she'll create new yeah which
doesn't even seem to occur to him and
it's like dude i think you're missing
the
think you got to think villain big
picture here
totally really small but also the idea
that like
vision is super intelligent in some
respects but also like come on like give
him some of the fandom wikis have him be
like
i believe i'm inside three's company
right now this
is eerily reminiscent of malcolm in the
middle
hmm yeah i i just i mean to me it was
like most shows you're on like a
straight line it's like you start here
you're gonna end up here and it's like a
journey to get there and like i don't
think there's a problem with this show
being
we're like peeling away layers trying to
figure out what's going on like that
works
i just feel like it it just it wore out
it's welcome it was the same beat
over and over of like something's wrong
in this world
wait a minute cut to credits and then
you do that again and again after a
while it was just like
all right let's let's let's move this
thing forward yeah all right
well let's move this thing forward
[Music]
because the big question of the series
isn't so much what's gonna happen
but more what the [ __ ] is even happening
i don't know
i don't know and i don't know in a story
that's really about wanda's grief and
finding acceptance
the acceptance that no matter how
original a marvel thing starts off
it still has to end with a sky beam and
two cgi dolls throwing particle effects
at each other
it's just so meaningful this reminds me
of my own struggles i'm sorry i just
need a second
but there's more to the show than an
expanding red bubble of sadness that
makes america great again
step outside the hecks to meet
characters like darcy
the latest phase of marvel's image rehab
campaign for thor the dark world
so pause um darcy something that didn't
i didn't have room to fit it in it's
like
for all the questions that people have
about magic like how does magic work in
marvel it's so like
not well explained anyone who's good at
science can just do anything in marvel
as well like darcy is a astrophysicist
like you know i imagine she studies uh
stars
and sp outer space and things of that
nature but she's like i've hacked past
the mainframe like i've unlocked all the
files
it's fine if you're good at science like
you know a little bit of
you know a little bit of everything i
think that's been true of like bruce
banner
of tony stark obviously like yeah it's
like if you have a career in stem
then that's it you can do whatever is
required of you and
even like dr helen cho and ultra creates
like the
the cradle for old you know like yeah
they're all just like
everyone in science is a science genius
and you can do anything technological
and all magic is
is science uh what would you call magic
my people call science
honestly there's a like science and
technology i feel like they take the
time
to sort of like here's everybody's got a
specialty and here's how this works
magic they're really at this point just
like uh so what's your
what color is your ball of goo like it
all is just everybody magic is like
shadowy goo color goo balls yeah well i
wasn't
it's purple but mine's red mirrors are
blue it's like i was
bummed out with the gooball fight at the
end because i think doctor strange
i don't need it explained but they made
the the dueling like look
interesting of like you know the
different portals and then all the whips
and the different
methods you could use like magic isn't
just really good about
imagining things you do with magic
during a fight like you throw a guy into
a portal or you'd make the building
go like that instead of upright you know
like and then this feels like yeah you
you build up a really hot ball of goo
and then you fling it
still dragon ball z school yeah grunting
and throwing
it's a little bit like at the very end
of harry potter where it's been like
eight movies building up to it and then
they just like shoot
goo out of their way
really again all right just a lot of
this sunset just a lot of
at least i will say goo fights are
better than the x-men like
jimmy wu the only cop who's also into
close-up magic that anyone could ever
love
and monica rambo who grows from a
knowing commentary on tv's black best
friend trope
into an actual example of tv's black
best friend trope they'll never know
what you sacrificed for them
and finally into a superhero who could
one day become
marvel's first black best friend trope
in space
together they'll take on some brand new
villains like this generic military jerk
ass
dottie who actually thought he doesn't
really matter and the head which in
charge
agatha hargness a well-brewed concoction
of one part maleficent
and two parts cruella de vil and i
killed sparky too
[Laughter]
let your love for katherine han blind
you to the fact that her plan doesn't
make a ton of sense
and her past implies that the salem
witch trials were kinda onto something
and despite what her absolute pop of the
theme song claims
she barely knows what's going on either
i need you to tell me how you did this
i couldn't make heads or tails of it
it's been wanda's repressed trauma all
along but agatha kind of knows turn that
direction
doesn't exactly top the charts though
huh
so what was agatha doing she so she
notices like there's a lot of magic
in the area and she kind of she sneaks
in i imagine she snuck in at some point
yeah and her plan was to just like
make her sad enough that she would give
up her powers
willingly even though she could absorb
them at any time
sure i i honestly like when you look at
it and they're all the things it's like
oh
it's been her she's doing all these
things it's like well what did what did
she actually
do they show her at the carnival where
you know where they did all the really
funny vision and
wanda magic gags and they show her doing
stuff i'm like i don't know what she's
doing in this to make any of this
it's just silly sitcom stuff so other
than when she kidnapped her and then
kidnapped that guy ralph and made fun of
him off camera over and over again
um i don't really know what she was
doing i
i feel like and and my guess would be
that there are
a few scenes on the cutting room floor
that like
transition this better but like my
thought is it's
it's really tooth like at first she's
just investigating like
for the first half of the show she's not
really taking it she's just trying to
figure out
who is doing this and why and how does
she have this power and
she doesn't know anything about you know
the the mind stone or whatever so she's
just thinking this is some witch and
she's somehow hiding as she's doing
her spells and i need to know about it
and then at some point like
between episodes four and five or
whatever
that's when she's like okay it's wanda
and she doesn't know what she's doing
and so i'm going to like convince her
it's a little bit like mysterio and far
from home is my read
i'm going to convince her that she can't
be trusted with these powers
and she needs to turn them over to me
for the common good
i think that's what she's trying to do
in the end which he's like look what
you're doing
heroes don't torture people like you
should give your powers to me because i
know what to do with them
and it just doesn't work that's my guess
okay now
who's making the commercials this is an
excellent question
this is i'm i'm really curious about
this well i understand your questions
yes who's making the commercials but
it's also why like
darcy picks up this tv signal that wanda
is
i i i guess purposefully sending out
that's probably just a side effect like
is it because
her magic like her subconscious is just
like i'm gonna live inside a tv show
and like the magic takes care of the
rest so she's not only creating a sitcom
for her to live in but she's creating a
broadcast signal like a sitcom would
have had
yeah with a gasoline i didn't even think
of that okay that seemed to be the
implication of like she was catching the
energy and like it was coming in as
pictures as a tv signal
right but obviously those commercials
were created
consciously like that there's there's
cleverness there
there thought there's thought behind no
because she's i don't think she's doing
any of it consciously like she's not
sitting down and like
making a pot of coffee and scripting
lines for the next day like this is all
just happening
she's a brilliant she's a really great
comedy writer like she said
like she should not be in the woods she
should just go to cbs studios and
she's too powerful yeah the way she's
able to balance uh
characters and pockets for an entire
town off the top of her head in real
time
these are thought out bits this is not
just like one-off like they're running
gags and stuff
i want to see her pitch deck i want to
see what she's working with yeah i want
to see her
yeah a stories b stories c
stories runners yeah i mean like chuck
laurie's taken some time to plan them
all out even tyler perry needs like a
day to knock one of these scripts out
but almost too powerful one day but yeah
yeah half a day
um there's a worksheet uh yeah you can
probably do two episodes a day at this
point
but he is an anomaly all right
too strong uh she needs to be nerfed
he's too powerful
okay keep going you a hardcore marvel
fan then you know
wandavision wasn't meant to be enjoyed
but dissected frame by frame
to predict what's coming next as the
show spawned a q anon style army of
forecasters
who were so sure that mephisto was
behind it all
the devils in the details bev that's not
the only place he is
nope just a deep cut easter egg evan
peters casting was proof of the
multiverse
wrong just an elaborate boner joke boner
and that the last episode had to have a
luke skywalker level cameo
i work with this actor that i have
always wanted to work with oh
and we have fireworks together
how about paul bedney giving himself
head instead
so pause i mean the only one of these
that i think
felt cheap or at least like i don't get
it is the
is the evan peters casting like
unless they're doing some reveal on top
of the reveal like the rumors that
they're gonna actually like say the
mandarin was actually an actor
playing an actor playing the real
mandarin or whatever
like that that to me goes over the line
of like knowing
nod or like homage or easter egg into
just like you're just messing with us
like
i i i don't get it i don't get why you
would do that
i think that they wanted the the
conversation like it's definitely just
there to mess with us for sure
um but i think that just knowing the you
know we've got doctor strange and the
the multiverse of madness and all that
stuff yeah they're messing with us
they're just having a little bit of a
lark
um which seems you know a little dickish
but i like it
uh i thought it was really fun it didn't
bug me as much as i know it bugged a lot
of people to be like well why would you
use him then
um didn't bother me at all i thought it
was like a little fun thing and i like
that he turned out to be ralph at the
end and tied those together
yeah i uh i think that's like the kind
of thing i could totally see the writers
coming up with and just being like oh
that's fun that'll be a fun little thing
to do with people
and and that you just didn't realize how
serious
the the fan community was going to take
it and how
disappointed they would be if it didn't
work out the way they wanted like i
think that
it's sometimes hard to predict how how
intense that stuff is going to become
i thought it was i thought it was fun
and i i i sort of guessed i thought
pretty quickly that
i don't think this is how you'll
introduce the x-men and i i don't even
think they're gonna want to introduce
the fox x-men
so that always seemed like kind of a
kind of an outside chance to me
i don't know i mean the the the amount
of
uh and by the way i would not have
noticed these if it wasn't for the
uh one division analysis industry that
popped up around it
but the amount of like of easter eggs
and deep cuts and references and
illusions that they did manage to pack
in would give you the impression that
like
oh this is a very thoughtful uh move on
their part and they're going to pay
these things off but then to be like
boner like what they don't get me wrong
in fairness 2-1 division they had
already introduced the concept before we
met evan peters
that everybody in town is just a regular
citizen of this town who's being mind
controlled so it wouldn't make any sense
it would make more sense as a viewer to
be like that's just some random guy
who's being convicted he had
super speed like he had super speed
powers just some
just some dudes it's also not the 50s
like the whole thing
is magic it's all magic well you can
dress up
and and make it look we can make it look
like the 50s right now you know put a
put a filter on i'll wear it i'll just
go
i can just go
and we'll pour a couple of high balls
yeah but now with your mind you'd have
to physically do it i'm just saying it's
a magic show you could just assume
everything's got a little sprinkling of
fairy dust on it yeah
i don't know i never thought they were
like oh this will be how they
i don't think kevin flankie wants to
bring the fox x-men
he wants to do his own thing i just want
terence howard to
to walk in at some point and be like
colonel rhodes
be like three plus three equals nine
magic
oh well maybe next season all right keep
going
why can't you just accept the fact that
the big bad for the mcu's first disney
plus series was grief does [ __ ] you have
to spell it out on an announcement board
or something
so if you've been feeling sad and
hopeless lately and just want to
mentally check out and fill all the
voids in your life with garbage tv
catch the story of a superhero who does
pretty much exactly that
and at the end of the day after all the
trauma follow her to the place all
marvel characters go once their arcs are
done
some lonely ass cabin in the woods
thank you to eric goldman for noticing
this
marvel retirement plan
i'll see you at curtin call that was
get radical skin thing cuddles and
kisses between his little ears
weekend at bed knees what white nonsense
is this
agatha crispy a spectrum representative
will arrive anytime between the hours of
one and nine pm
save the cat whose clues wrecking ralph
the only way ralph would remember our
anniversary is if there was a beer named
june
2nd what ralph could really use is how
to goose your wife so you don't
lose your wife ralph looks better in the
dark so i'm not complaining
not that ralph ever wants to eat
anything other than baked beans which
explains a lot about his personal appeal
mind you you sure you don't want an
audience volunteer named
my husband brown hey where'd you blow me
wanda's twin powers activate going
through hex
and what is this show if not joy
disappearing do you have a brother mom
he's far away from here and that makes
me
sad sometimes he was killed by ultron
maria died three years ago before
one i can't remember my life before west
view i don't know who i am you probably
suppressed a lot of the trauma
you're so crippled by your own
self-doubt
all you people who left still have the
luxury of optimism
you have no idea what it was like oh
it's lost
i only remember uh
joestar uh saw a cut of this and said
it's too much sadness and i said no it
only gets fun here as it goes
oh my god you'd be the judge um uh
i just thought that uh it's one of those
things where when you put it all
together back to back um
man the show had a lot of down moments
um i was really
only keeping track of like nose
scrunches
and sad moments and i still had like a
spreadsheet page
i was surprised yeah anyways let's keep
going with this ad
i only remember feeling completely alone
endless nothingness so much
trauma zukana will be sorrow can it
parents dead brother dead
vision dead i have a daughter if you
could just get her out of her room
if i could just hold her i can't feel
you
thanks for choosing me to be your mom
you are my salmons
pecks in the city
if one ever needs backup she should just
call her neighbor murtaugh from lethal
weapon
i'm too old for this who noticed that
that's a great point
i was uh i was looking up uh uh where
they shot it just because i had a
feeling that there would be something
like this like because i knew they used
they tried to recreate the old sitcom
feel so it's warner brothers ranch um
and they've shot a million things there
but
specifically that house was uh
and then of course like i don't know
because modern movie making or tv
it's like they completely digitally
altered wanda's house like they removed
the second story
and like changed some of the decorations
on it like because they could
because they like you science has gone
too far um
but but dottie's is a is is exactly
murtaugh's house that uh
unfortunately on her front lawn that's
where riggs and
gary busey had their yeah their big uh
their big flash
apart the house is destroyed by an
exploding toilet in the sequel
in the sequel yes in lethal parts
um so we got we're talking more wanna
division we're gonna get to all your
questions
um so thank you for watching so far
please subscribe
hit like hit that bell so you never miss
another video and there's more videos to
come baby because we've got
the fandom five trivia contest for the
mcu
you probably know your mcu by now so uh
uh click the link inside
and sign up and reel uh win real
money for all that made up knowledge um
this should be a fun one
lon i'm sure you've got some heaters
some heaters coming yeah we try you know
it's hard for me to tell because i've
had to watch these movies so many times
at this point just for
all the stuff that we do uh it's hard
it's a little hard for me to calibrate
so i ran the questions by a few other
people to make sure they're not
too easy or too hard and i i hope
they're right in the pocket
yeah and then there's provision in there
some wand division of course
uh some uh something i'm really excited
about this friday 10 a.m
be here be square be loaded up on
mountain dew like we are gonna be
because we're watching the snyder cut
all together as a gang um
we'll be watching the whole four hours
uh we'll be commentating
we'll be analyzing we will be chugging
mountain dew um
yeah that's real i just want to make
some people know spencer's not joking
about that
do the do with us uh and get ready for
the snyder cut
experience let it wash over you as it
will wash over us and we'll all emerge
changed uh we'll join us in the sun um
after we finish the snyder cut for the
dark side
um i'm i'm genuinely curious you know i
think that it'll be yeah
uh it'll i kind of wish we could take it
into chunks but
like we're gonna watch it as the auteur
intended and do all four hours in a row
and see what happens i i i i feel like
as somebody who's
been making a lot of jokes the whole
time about this item because
how else can you respond to something
like this uh i'm
i'm very excited and curious to finally
see it like i'm not that cynical that i
don't really want to see what
the hell this guy's come up with yeah i
think if uh
if nothing else he can cr he can craft a
cool visual
but it's all the talking in between that
we will we will dive into
and and uh and do ourselves up to the
gills
because i'm excited i haven't had
mountain dew in such a long time so i'm
really excited to get into that
especially
um moving on fan questions uh oh we have
actually have outtakes
uh i think for this episode let's see
what those might have been
it still has to end with a sky beam and
two cgi dolls throwing particle effects
at each other
the purple goo symbolizes repression
starring it was miss scarlet with the
dark hole in the suburban mine prison
a witch called wanda lil uzivert
paranoid android robo pop
why not sent the zoidberg double vision
even more british vision han solo
the long haun i'll get you my pretty and
your little dog too
rambo first brood toyona powers
the quick and the dead that's bait
meta man weird science two broke worlds
we brought a woo golly g-man the creep
state
sword bish generic soldier guys walking
purposefully around
a base
i want that job the olson's twins
honey i spawned the kids nick at
nightception
magic the bantering kiss viz bang bang
thousands of people under your thumb
all interacting with each other
according to complex storylines
well that's the mcu baby
well there you go uh yeah some
interesting uh
interesting goofy names there right
that's always fun uh but
yeah but more interesting are your
questions um specifically
thor buttock ass
cause but also his butt his thor
buttocks
play on words yeah it's like sore
buttocks i get it um so agnes
is living on the streets now yes unless
the resident's out of hatred for wanda
decide to help her and try to bring
witch agatha back
this is a great point it's not just that
she's stuck in this personality she
doesn't she can't get a credit card she
has no id
she doesn't really have a place to live
this is this is horrible she's playing
in the 80s
or or 50s or whatever decade she sent
her back to
cartoon character in presumably the real
world of of east view or whatever
the the town is right yeah yep yeah yes
okay that sucks to be her um
just add another tortured person to her
i mean are we imagining that all of
those other people are going to like
remember
everything that happened to that like
they don't get mind wiped or anything
no they're they're pissed off like oh
that's that witch that's been imprisoned
in our town
yeah we'll keep her as a pet yeah but
they won't know she's a witch
all they'll know is like this was
another townsfolk that was stuck with us
well no because they were there for the
final battle right they don't get their
brains
deleted were they there for that i
thought they did
people when agatha and
and wondering each other interesting but
they'll be like okay that person was
fighting wanda she's probably one of the
good guys like i'm like
like kitty foreman is gonna go home and
be like red
there's a witch in town and she thinks
she's our neighbor
she tried to save us from the one that
was torturing our brains
i love purple goo let's have a look i
can't believe
uh red has been like presumably locked
in a closet so she could think she was
married to that other guy
yeah um evan j pretzel writes uh
if marvel or dc could do another period
piece what characters do you want to see
and where
personally i want 80s punisher i would
love an 80s punisher movie yeah
yeah yeah like yeah like new york in
like the 70s and 80s like
it was still really gross and scuzzy and
yeah that would be great
yeah grimy punisher for sure uh i always
think like to me
part of the reason that we can't quite
thread the needle on fantastic four
is that it makes so much sense as like a
a space age
atomic age cold war like it's so
60s to me that and i'm not saying you
can't do it i'm sure there's somebody
out there has a great idea for how to do
it but
that to me would be really fun to be
like a throwback 60s style fantastic
four
adventure yeah yeah i'd like to see like
uh
you know those 90s outdoor adventures
that they would do i think that that
could be kind of fun with like the hulk
you know just because like we used to
have all the power rangers and making
things grow
and i think that could be like a you
know almost like a sentai version of
thor or
thor uh the hulk that could be a little
almost almost like taking i love this it
would be like taking the classic culk tv
show
right and set it in that era but do that
but like as a marvel movie that's
awesome yeah
that could be great i always wanted to
see speaking of the fantastic four like
i really wish we got
noah holly's uh dr doom yeah movie
um i don't know when victor von doom was
actually
born like world war one or world war ii
right
by the cold war he's the dictator of
latvaria so it'd have to be
you know 30 years before that or so yeah
yeah and like you know he just has a he
has like a he's a baron or something
like that he's some type of
landed gentry before he became doctor
doom so i think a period piece
for for his origin would have been would
have been pretty sweet
he's like a hot duke it'd be like
bridgerton yeah it'd be pretty
he would shoot into the air um
okay anyways um uh let's see
uh jared johnson wonders how long until
we see white vision again
does he become a running cameo i mean
yeah of course like no one ever really
dies
in marvel until their contracts expire
so i think that
he'll probably pop up again gosh
whenever they want him to but i don't
think they'll they'll i don't think
they'll throw him into
a another tv show i think he'll pop up
in like captain marvel 2
or or doctor strange in the multiverse i
i mean him saying i am vision before he
leaves he's like well
we've got a new vision yeah yeah i feel
like he's definitely going to come back
at some point
he's gotta go find himself in space
right yeah he's in a
space cabin in the space woods
um let's see so james brophy writes do
you ever want worry about doing an
honest trailer too soon i'm curious
because
how much of this is you guys figuring
out what happened and still wiring parts
together
uh i i have the opposite worries that we
wait too long um
and uh we've kind of forgotten and
nobody cares and we're repeating
observations and jokes that other people
have made 17 times before
so that's i'm more concerned about being
stale and repetitive than
than being too soon and uh and i think
that
i don't know i think we can be more
honest the sooner it is because that's
when it's fresh in everybody's head and
it you really capture the experience
which
for most people was like wait what's
going on um i don't think that's the
honest experience is
is knowing every answer about
wandavision when you watch it like
we're trying to we're trying to sell you
on the real the real deal here i don't
know what do you guys think
yeah i agree like we don't want to be
doing jokes that ever because because
this was such a like um you know the
whole group was watching together like
this was really
like a great example of when we can do
appointment television
um as a group and twitter's kind of
losing it without it and we need another
one to come back soon
um but because of that there are just
like tons of running jokes and a lot of
things and it gets it
it gets really hard to make sure you're
not just repeating stuff
that you saw people making the same joke
over and over and over again
um on there so yeah i agree yeah i i in
some ways it's
it's the hardest to do stuff like this
that everybody's watching together
and making jokes on social media the
whole time and then as soon as it ends
we try to do it because then it's like
well yeah i mean a lot of the things
that you would most obviously point out
are the exact same things everybody's
been making their own jokes about for
weeks and you don't want to just
retread so in some ways it's a lot
harder to do something like this than it
would be
you know terminator dark fate or some
random movie that comes and goes and
then you get to bring your own take to
it
um and this one will end on this one
this is fascinating to me because i
actually don't know the answer uh matan
valensky writes
why do you think that people uh in
charge of heavily theorized series like
game of thrones west world star wars
sequels
make the decisions they make uh i'm
translating roughly here it's like do
you think that they are
reacting to or responding to people's
online theories
um during these hugely popular
shows do you think that they are ever
reading these boards and
and is that informing what they're doing
or and i think they mean like subverting
them specifically like they it seems
like they're going against or subverting
they guess the fan theory is that's what
their question is
um and i mean my assumption is like just
because of production schedules and like
the way these things are scripted and
approved so far in advance
is that it's pretty much impossible to
react to fan theories
except when you have like a a break
like you can have like between season
one and season two right then you can
catch up
yeah but it's undeniable that the
creators of some of these shows that do
have these multi-seasons
are looking at what people are saying
and then future seasons react
like westworld is the clearest example
where
they did season one it came out and
everybody kind of figured out the the
twist too early like that
people were dissatisfied with season one
because they put together one of the big
revelations just by talking on the
internet and so in future seasons
they either didn't hint so much early on
that there was going to be a twist or
did other things to subvert the
expectations
specifically because they must have gone
back and seen what happened in season
one
so i like lost two i think is a pretty
good example of that where
later seasons were obviously reacting to
things people liked or didn't like or
you know like if the hurley bird became
a huge internet thing it's like well
let's bring that back you know
yeah i do think there's time also like
because you know
even if you're green lit for production
and your scripts are locked like even on
as they're shooting the finale i don't
know do you think that they were
still shooting when this show premiered
or do you think that everything was
completely done
no problem because there's so much
visualization that needs to be done
i think they're wrapped the production
is wrapped by the time
the first episode debuts for almost any
show certainly any streaming show
yeah so i guess for a show like this
yeah for a show like this and
and game of thrones and you know just
because the sheer amount of time that
rendering takes and stuff like that
everything's done uh
was like the season would begin and they
were working like a few months ahead but
they you know they weren't making the
end of the season until a few months
before it so the season had already
started
but now it's just eight to ten episode
seasons total they're
it's like a film they make it they
produce it they yeah
and then they decide if they want to do
another but believe me they are reading
and watching
and if they ever come back for season
two you'll get uh
you'll get twice the double mephisto
reveals um
you'll get triple triple the flies
everyone's just gonna be covered in
flats
did you i don't know if you saw this
week that feige's been talking about
sequel
like second seasons for some of these
shows yeah that they're never going to
announce in advance because it would
tell you too much about where the mcu is
going
but he is saying some of them will come
back for season two so you just don't
want to stay in advance
yeah i mean there's like the potential
to just do one division the lost
episodes because it seemed like
the the tv show was running like 24 7
like that darcy was watching there can
be so many
other episodes um i would like to see
uh like if you do another season do
drama
series instead of like sitcoms this time
like i'd like to see juan to do like
her take on house what's her ozark yeah
exactly
yeah law and order could be great like
yes like that
like like wanda envisioned recreating
like other kinds of shows from the 70s
80s 90s
90s reality tv um that'd be great
uh temptation island one division
all right you guys uh this was super fun
we had a lot of fun watching and writing
this
i hope you did too uh and i hope you had
fun watching it so please come back next
week when we'll be doing the same thing
for uh a film that some people say
should have the glow uh but it doesn't
so
come back next week for another episode
of honest trailer commentaries and keep
checking back on phantom
team for all the cool stuff we do thanks
a lot bye-bye
[Music]
you